oh
that really hurt who throws a shoe
crack a cold one with dad and please
keep your shoes on because we
fondly know what penny was up to after
the big bang theory
bazinga you've fallen victim to another
one of my classic practical jokes
the flight attendant is an eight episode
thriller from hbo max and in this video
we're gonna crack its mystery and show
how they've set up events for a
potential season two so put your tray
table up
like and subscribe and make sure your
seat is in an upright position because
here we
go it's actually quite fitting that the
final episode begins in a liquor store
our protagonist cassie bowden is a
raging alcoholic who denies her
addiction at every turn
we've gone over this i'm not an
alcoholic i am not an alcoholic
that's because she uses alcohol to block
out trauma in her life
specifically an event that happened when
she was 10 when her alcoholic father
ended up killing himself and two others
in a case of drunk driving
she was so drunk being given alcohol
from her father at a young age
that she misremembered several key
moments in her childhood like the time
she thought she spent a great day with
her dad winning an egg racing
competition but forgetting he made a
drunken fool out of himself in front of
the whole school
or the time her father pushed her
brother davey during her birthday it's
this refusal to acknowledge the truth
about her past
that causes friction between her and her
brother
i'm sorry that you choose to remember
things that way
because i had hoped that you'd finally
see things the way they really were
and this drinking is what helps cassie
cope with the death of alex sokolov
in episode one she hooks up with him
after meeting him on a flight to bangkok
only for her to wake up next to him with
his throat slashed the series then
follows her as she uncovers the mystery
of his death
as she simultaneously tries to avoid
capture alex ends up
living in her mind providing clues and
exposition as she struggles to piece
together what happened the night of his
murder but if cassie is really gonna
solve this case and stop the hitman on
her tail
she'll need to overcome her addiction
and come to terms with her past
but before we can get into that miranda
who cassie initially thought was alex's
murderer
teams up with her to take down a man
known as victor
in episode 7 we learned that alex stole
200 million dollars from this guy after
finding out his parents company and
victors
were engaging in a legal arms trade
specifically the selling of batteries
that charge rocket-propelled grenades
miranda was in charge of
tracking alex down but really just
wanted the money for herself
now victor thinks either miranda or
cassie has his money and will continue
sending goons after them until they're
both
dead meanwhile the fbi agents in charge
of the case have just found out cassie's
fingerprints were found on the bottle
they believed to be the murder weapon
used in alex's death but something about
this feels off to agent kim hammond
miranda and cassie concocked a plan to
stop
felix the guy who actually killed alex
he actually became romantically involved
with cassie in order to find out if she
knew where that money really was
what felix doesn't know is that alex's
copy of crime and punishment holds
within it the encryption key and
password
for the bank account which has all the
money a book he gets a hold of at the
end of episode 7 and gives to victor
miranda goes rogue and goes after victor
knowing that he'll stop at nothing until
she's dead
she ends up killing him getting herself
shot in the process
making for one very awkward plane ride
as she tries to catch up with cassie but
the question remains if miranda has the
book the money and has killed victor
why get on a plane to help cassie well
as she explains
i have to stop a woman from being killed
and i'm not sure that i fully understand
my feelings about that because i've
never done anything
purely selfless before back at the fbi
annie gives agent hammond the usb her
boyfriend max and cassie obtained from
victor's secret servers way back in
episode 5. these contain
financial records forged flight
documents weapon sales and a whole slew
of incriminating files that will allow
his company
and alex's parents to be taken down
annie also notices that the man cassie
was seeing who we know to be the hitman
felix
is on the bangkok security footage on
kim's computer
a detail that allows kim to figure out
that felix is the murderer
arriving in italy cassie enlists the
help of her friend enrico to get a hold
of a gun
it just so happens his grandfather was a
former comp who has one lying around but
enrico's nona has a heart to heart with
cassie after she finds out she's the one
looking for the weapon
ibambini cuando chris conor
this hits cassie hard as she is
repeating the same mistakes her father
did
she like him has turned into an
alcoholic and threatens to hurt not only
herself but those around her
her entire life she has been running
from her traumatic childhood she feels
responsible for the death of her father
and the two innocent people he killed
even telling grown-up cassie in her
flashback that
she's sorry it's only now when she
confronts it that she can leave her
vodka bottles behind and begin her
journey to sobriety you may have even
noticed the presence of a rabbit
in this case symbolizing innocence and
heroism this symbolism appears all
throughout the series
symbolism ever heard of it in episode 2
which is actually
titled rabbits cassie knocks over a
giant rabbit sculpture right after being
told the sculpture's name
the piece is called heroism in the face
of the modern world
and all of its very many hardships back
at the hotel enrico asks if she wants
something from the minibar and this is
the first time in the series
she declines a drink he goes off to get
some coffee when felix attacks
cassie from the shower there's a whole
fight scene where she defends herself
and
rico even comes in and is stabbed but
she's able to get the upper hand and
shoot him but in a surprise twist
cassie's flight attendant partner shane
comes in and performs the finishing blow
in the next scene we find out
shane is cia tasked with keeping tabs on
megan
another flight attendant who is giving a
proprietary technology from her
husband's laptop to the north koreans
yeah it's pretty crazy to be fair megan
didn't know it was going to the north
koreans she thought it was going to a
rival competitor but one thing led to
another and before she knew it she was
in too
deep kind of like what happened to
cassie before cassie's flight to rome
she remarks on how megan's luggage was
so heavy it looked like she was moving
and given megan's heartbreaking call to
her son saying she loves him
we can kind of see where season 2
storyline may pick up
megan is a wanted woman for the
knowledge she gave to the north koreans
and is now on the run and shane having
told cassie his boss wants to talk to
her about becoming a quote human
asset may see cassie becoming some sort
of spy that has to track down megan
in the aftermath of the hotel attack we
find that enrico made it out alive and
so did felix so who knows if he'll come
back in some capacity cassie arrives
back in new york
where she finally patches things up with
her brother apologizes and promises
things are going to be different
she even sits down with her best friend
annie who she had a falling out with a
few episodes ago and cassie shows how
she's been to alcoholics anonymous with
one of her chips
she's already been to two meetings bonus
points if you caught miranda sneaking
the crime and punishment book into
cassie's jacket
at the end of the episode we find out
she's given back alex's book however
this time the page with a bank account
info has been
ripped out and replaced with a note took
the page in the money but you should
have the book
see you soon em miranda has taken the
200 million and says she'll see cassie
soon leaving us with the possibility
she'll be back for season two
you may also have noticed the
highlighted quote on the left here
the same line miranda quoted to cassie
in episode 7.
would not one tiny crime be wiped out by
a thousand good deeds
this feeds into the main plot of crime
and punishment about an ex-student who
thinks killing for money will get him
out of poverty and allow him to go on
and perform many great deeds
but all this does is end up racking him
with confusion paranoia and disgust for
what he has done did alex think that by
stealing this money he could go on to do
good things
didn't just sit back and say oh well i
guess i'm a criminal now
i deserve shots
[Music]
what will miranda do with the money
given her past life will she do good
deeds in an attempt at redemption or
will she like the character in crime and
punishment succumb to confusion and
paranoia back at her job cassie takes a
look at a liquor bottle something she'd
normally have a few of before a flight
but this time she puts it back another
reminder of how her character has
changed and that change manifests in her
mind as she is no longer haunted by alex
the lights turn off in the hotel room as
this chapter of her life is put behind
her she has confronted her past and
overcome her fears
and now her mind is clear thanks for
watching everyone if you liked the video
be sure to give it a like and subscribe
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much